qué tal lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es una gráfica del producto
interno bruto en función del tiempo
entonces déjame dibujar por acá los ejes
aquí vamos a tener el producto interno
bruto y de este lado vamos a tener el
tiempo y este de acá el producto interno
bruto va a estar en términos reales y
una verdadera medida que indique cómo va
cambiando considerando la inflación y
todo eso entonces acá es producto
interno bruto real y acá es tiempo
tiempo y podemos pensar lo que es en
años o en décadas o algo más o menos a
largo plazo bueno para hacer esta
gráfica vamos a hacer algunas
suposiciones déjame escribirlo por acá
posiciones suposiciones que son pues
razonables y la primera suposición que
vamos a hacer es que conforme va pasando
el tiempo la población aumenta entonces
que la población población aumenta lo
cual es razonable verdad cada vez nacen
más personas la población va creciendo
esa es la primera suposición y la
segunda es que la productividad del país
o de la economía que estemos estudiando
la productividad
productividad
también aumenta así y hay varias razones
por las cuales la productividad puede
aumentar déjame escribir aquí algunas no
sé una podría ser un aumento en
tecnología en tecnología
tecnología si hay una mejor tecnología
que haya base científico se puede
producir más también puede ser que se
descubran nuevos recursos nuevos
recursos naturales una nueva mina de oro
o un nuevo yacimiento petrolero recursos
esto también aumentaría la productividad
y también pues podría haber nuevos
procesos para hacer negocios que se
pueden pensar como nueva tecnología pero
le voy a poner nuevos procesos así que
esto puede ser común
como esto del internet verdad
crecimiento del internet entonces hay
nuevas formas de vender entonces esto de
la productividad básicamente es cuánto
produce cada persona y en realidad estas
suposiciones no están tan locas la de la
población es muy razonable y la de la
productividad se da en muchas de las
economías con el paso del tiempo hay
nuevos descubrimientos científicos
nuevos descubrimientos de recursos que
hacen que se produzca más entonces bajo
estas suposiciones el producto interno
bruto debería de ir aumentando conforme
transcurre el tiempo verdad o sea uno se
esperaría el producto interno bruto se
viera más o menos así que tuviera una
tendencia hacia arriba a esta de acá le
voy a llamar la línea de tendencia lo
voy a poner aquí tendencia
tendencia y si en realidad si sucede que
conforme pasa el tiempo el producto
interno bruto real de un país o de una
economía aumenta o sea si va creciendo
así a largo plazo sin embargo a corto
plazo no es algo tan sencillo a corto
plazo no se ve como una línea recta sino
que tenemos pues unas ciertas
oscilaciones que voy a dibujar por acá
entonces a corto plazo el producto
interno bruto más bien se ve así pero
voy a poner unas cuantas ondas va para
arriba de la tendencia luego por abajo
luego por arriba
un poco por abajo luego por arriba luego
por abajo y así sigue oscilando
alrededor de esta línea de tendencia a
esto de aquí se le conoce como el ciclo
económico déjame escribirlo por acá
arriba es el ciclo económico
económico y básicamente lo que dice es
que a corto plazo la economía produce
más de lo que puede incluso más de lo
que indica la tendencia pero luego
produce por debajo de la tendencia pues
teniendo una recesión luego otra vez la
economía se expande rzd se expande rzd
entonces la idea básicamente es que no
tiene un crecimiento constante si tiene
estos altibajos que ves por acá entonces
bueno esto de ciclo económico podría ser
un poco engañoso la palabra ciclo podría
indicarnos que que es fácil de predecir
verdad que cierta cantidad de años hay
una alta y cierta cantidad de años
después hay una baja y así pero en
realidad no es así esto no pasa así
aunque aquí la gráfica se vea muy como
con forma de función trigonométricas
como de seno o de coseno en realidad
esto del ciclo económico es súper
difícil de predecir le voy a poner aquí
que es difícil de predecir
de predecir
en realidad hay muchos factores que
alteran osea no existe la misma cantidad
de tiempo entre una montaña y otra o
bien entre una depresión y otra en esta
gráfica de acá así que pues los
economistas están muy muy como
confundidos con por qué sucede esto de
aqaba entonces déjame contarte bien bien
cómo se llaman cada una de estas etapas
hay básicamente dos etapas una en la que
la economía aumenta y otra en la cual
baja
y se llaman de la siguiente manera en
efecto en esta etapa cuando la economía
está produciendo más y va hacia arriba
esta etapa de por acá se le conoce como
expansión si lo voy a poner aquí
expansión y se dice que la economía se
está expandiendo expansión por otro lado
cuando disminuye cuando tenemos una
tendencia de ir hacia abajo a esto de
acá se le conoce como contracción como
contracción de la economía
con tracción o bueno si quieres un
término un poco similar esa expansión
también se le conoce como reflexión
recesión y entonces tenemos expansión y
tenemos una contracción pero también se
le conoce como recesión y hay un término
pues adicional para cuando tenemos una
recesión muy muy grave cuando nuestra
recesión es así súper grave se le conoce
como depresión depresión y de hecho hay
un chiste de la definición entre de la
distinción entre recesión y depresión se
dice que si despiden a tu vecino
entonces es una recesión pero si te
despiden a cientos ella es una depresión
jaja bueno la cosa es que los
economistas no entienden muy bien esto
de acá
o sea y pues se confunden mucho incluso
este pues pues osea parecería ser que la
tendencia debería de ir hacia arriba y
por esto se tiene que explicar pues con
algún tipo de modelo o algo por el
estilo entonces pues por esta razón
después vamos a estudiar algunos vídeos
este acerca de la oferta agregada y la
demanda agregada y así pero la cosa y
que es muy importante que quiero
explicar en este vídeo es que todos
estos modelos los oferta agregada
demanda agregada y otros cuantos más
encuentra las emociones humanas y la
idea eso es algo muy importante dentro
de las emociones humanas tenemos la
capacidad de extrapolar a corto plazo
tenemos miedo tenemos impredictibilidad
tenemos un montón de cosas locas que
hacen los humanos que no entran en esos
modelos ahorita ya pues hay algunas
tendencias de finanzas y de economía
digamos finanzas de comportamiento que
empiezan a tomar en cuenta eso de que
los humanos pues también tienen su
corazoncito pero pues ahorita en estos
vídeos o en los siguientes vídeos no
vamos a ver eso sale bueno ahorita bueno
es importante mencionar los por que yo
estuve trabajando como analista en una
empresa así económica y si me quedó muy
claro que son una parte fundamental nada
más que no entran dentro de los modelos
porque no los podemos meter pues en
líneas y en ecuaciones y en cosas por el
estilo va entonces a mí me queda
clarísimo que pues todo esto tiene que
ver con las emociones humanas porque ver
o sea en este momento de por acá pues
las personas están muy muy tristes
verdad ya tiene mucho tiempo que la
economía disminuyó
están pagándoles muy poquito están algo
deprimidas entonces ven que no hay
esperanza pero luego la economía empieza
a crecer un poquito la gente sigue pues
como un poco desconfiada no quieren
invertir tanto pero empiezan a ver que
las fábricas empiezan a tener éxito ya
no empieza a ver tantos despidos en
realidad ya como que las cosas empiezan
a mejorar que sucede la gente empieza a
tener confianza por aquí ya más o menos
dice nada está muy padre esto de
invertir
estamos ganando mucho dinero vamos a
realizar más inversiones entonces se
invierte en crece todavía más el ciclo
están así extasiados están súper felices
se sienten súper contentos de que la
economía les vaya súper bien se empiezan
a sobre confiar empiezan a subestimar el
riesgo empiezan a hacer malas
inversiones verdad empiezan a invertir
demás empiezan a competir pues de
maneras poco saludables empiezan a
digamos llevar la economía más allá de
lo que puede llevarse entonces qué pasa
esas inversiones empiezan a caer se
empiezan a dar cuenta que no son tan
buenas entonces la gente empieza a dudar
empieza a desconfiar un poco luego aquí
pues ya estamos por debajo de la
productividad la que dice chin si no se
está yendo mal entonces empieza a ver
miedo empieza a ver pánico se empiezan a
vender muchas acción
luego venimos para acá abajo la gente se
empieza a poner muy triste hay despidos
masivos la gente se empieza a deprimir
de nuevo y llegamos aquí otra vez al
punto de abajo que es otra vez el ciclo
y volvemos a empezar sí entonces pues va
entonces esto ya que es más o menos una
explicación básica pero para explicarlo
todavía mejor aquí arriba dibuje una
gráfica y esta gráfica y este se puede
se puede ver en muchos correos cadena
que luego envían cuando hay épocas de
crisis y así que tiene más que ver con
bueno en esos correos tiene más que ver
con con acciones con ciclos de el
mercado de acciones pero pues como las
acciones y la economía están muy
entrelazadas entre sí también podemos
utilizar esta misma gráfica para
explicar por qué las emociones son
importantes en este en este ciclo
económico entonces más o menos la
gráfica dice así otra vez hay aquí un
cierto momento en el cual hay optimismo
o sea la gente empieza a confiar que las
cosas van bien las cosas empiezan a ir
bien la gente se emociona
la gente dice guau todo está súper padre
ahorita y pues ya no están despidiendo a
nadie hay trabajo constante luego
empieza a avanzar más y más la economía
hay un gran entusiasmo la gente dice wow
esta economía es fantástica puedo
invertir en lo que sea aquí empiezan a
comprar acciones de gatos puntocom o lo
que se empiezan a hacer muchas
inversiones llegan a este punto de acá
que es el punto de euforia la gente está
súper feliz la gente dice wow puede
aumentar el dinero por los cielos este
entonces sigo invirtiendo sigo
invirtiendo más en gatos puntocom
entonces la gente empieza a subestimar
el riesgo se da cuenta que gatos
puntocom y otras páginas de internet en
realidad eran negocios ficticios
negocios fantasmas empieza a bajar la
economía hay otras inversiones que ya no
funcionan hubo este mucho riesgo causado
en esta etapa de acá la gente empieza a
tener un poco de ansiedad porque pues
hay un poquito de después de dinero que
que ya no estaba funcionando y así que
se está perdiendo hay riqueza que se
está destruyendo pero pues nuevas es
tanta ansiedad luego empieza a bajar las
cosas se ponen mal pero la gente entra
en una etapa de negación diciendo no
puede ser que nos vaya tan mal o sea
ahorita ya hay muchas tecnologías como
el internet y las casas están aumentando
de precio entonces pues no seguro las
cosas van a ir bien pero siguen
empeorando
la gente ahora sí empieza a tener mucho
miedo luego pasan a la desesperación y
en este punto de desesperación es cuando
empiezan a vender las acciones empieza
nada ahora sí ya no a prestar nada de
dinero empieza a ver muchos despidos ya
no hay tantos inventarios que se compren
y que se vendan después la gente pasa a
esta etapa de recapitulación y dice
prendo peso que ya las cosas están mal
vamos a aceptarlo vamos a intentar
trabajar al respecto luego pasan a una
etapa de desprendimiento de emociones ya
se sienten pues más o menos tristes como
muy indiferentes hacia todo y de hecho a
un inversionista experto te diría que
esta de acá es la mejor etapa para para
invertir y ésta de acá es la peor etapa
para invertir va bueno está esta etapa
de desprendimiento pero bueno ya
empiezan a trabajar un poco más luego
hay una etapa de depresión porque aunque
mejoró la economía ya han pasado muchos
años estoy acá es un ciclo de años en el
cual no hemos sentido estas emociones
padres verdad y el optimismo la emoción
entonces la gente está deprimida pero
luego empieza a ver que si la economía
está mejorando hay un poco de esperanza
después se ve que mejora todavía más
llegamos al alivio y finalmente llegamos
y volvemos a empezar con el ciclo vale
entonces aquí vemos porque las emociones
humanas son importantes eso de las
emociones causan que los humanos tengan
ciertas acciones que vayan modificando
el ciclo económico
ahora como te comentaba en los
siguientes vídeos vamos a ver modelos
muy técnicos que no toman en cuenta las
emociones humanas pero desde mi punto de
vista es algo artificial porque en
realidad si son un factor importantísimo